three weeks now by the russian
federation sexuality
the reality the civilians the deaths of
innocent civilians as well as
journalists and medical personnel
it is the chaos created
they were forced
[Music]
[Music]
a
we are
is
people
the international community is united in
its massive accommodations
many countries france have immediately
taken measures
targeting russian authorities and
economic circles close to ocean power to
cut off access to their resources
these sanctions
foreign
thank you president i also would like to
thank under secretary general de carlo
assistant high commissioner mazu and
director general dr teddrus for their
very sobering briefings
their messages are grim very grim
we commend all humanitarian
organizations working to alleviate the
man-made catastrophe
being visited on ukraine
president the cause of this catastrophe
is clear
three short weeks ago as we sat in this
very chamber as the secretary general
pleaded for peace the russian federation
invaded ukraine
since then
we have witnessed wanton devastation in
a sovereign independent nation
with no regard for human life
date over three million people have had
to flee ukraine becoming refugees in
neighboring countries
we heard today ninety percent of those
forced out of their homes and into
uncertainty
are women and children
families torn apart
at least two million people are
internally displaced
increasingly vulnerable and in need of
immediate
ordinary people traumatized by a cruel
and reckless war
women and girls face heightened risk of
being subjected to sexual and
gender-based violence
including rape and trafficking
their right to protection is being
ignored
the destruction of the basic services
all of us here at this table take for
granted food water sanitary systems
health and education is having a
devastating effect in ukraine
civilian casualties we know are in the
thousands
irish journalist pierre sachelski
was tragically killed alongside
ukrainian journalist sasha kushnova
they were both working to shine a light
on ukraine crane's plight
our thoughts are with their families and
every grieving and suffering ukrainian
family
courageous journalists are showing the
horrific impact of russian aggression
i salute the free media putting their
lives on the line to show us the truth
the humanitarian impact of this war is
being felt around the world
it will affect the food security of
countries heavily reliant on ukrainian
agricultural products including in
africa asia and the middle east
it will cause severe harm far beyond the
borders of ukraine
president i find it a damning indictment
that this council has to plead with the
russian federation
not to deprive civilian populations of
food and water
not to deny them the basic
infrastructure they need for daily
existence
for survival
it's a damning indictment
that we in this council have not been
able to speak with the united voice to
save innocent lives in this war
president the images from a besieged
mario paul are shocking
we see once again
that urban warfare takes the heaviest
toll on civilians
we deplore the targeting of health care
facilities doctors taken hostage
life-saving care interfered with by
military forces
last week's attack by russian forces on
a maternity hospital in mariopol plumbed
new deaths
resulting in the death of a mother and
her newborn baby
a baby that never had a chance
we have to ask how many more
the residents of mario paul have are now
melting snow or siphoning water from
heating systems to quench their thirst
they're cutting down trees for firewood
for cooking and to stay warm in freezing
night temperatures
the city's supermarket's emptied because
the basic necessities of life cannot be
safely brought into the city
it is chilling to think that the
suffering forced unmarriable
may be visited on other ukrainian cities
there can be no justification for this
brutal aggression
it should never have been perpetrated it
must be stopped
ireland calls on the russian federation
to comply with its obligations to
protect civilian health care facilities
and medical and humanitarian personnel
it must facilitate the safe passage and
unhindered delivery of humanitarian
assistance including medical and food
supplies whatever is agreed or not
agreed on humanitarian corridors or
other measures
civilians and civilian infrastructure
must be protected under international
humanitarian law
this applies both to those who choose to
leave
and those who choose to remain
surely
the most basic respect for human life
must mean something to the aggressor
even now
let's be clear the provision of
humanitarian assistance is not dependent
on a ceasefire
it is dependent on those bombing cities
doing the right thing in accordance with
their obligations
president attacks directed against civil
civilians and civilian objects
indiscriminate attacks and
disproportionate attacks
are all prohibited under international
humanitarian law ireland remains gravely
concerned by the humanitarian harm
arising from use of explosive weapons in
populated areas in ukraine
there have been reports of the use of
cluster munitions and thermalbaric
weapons by russian military forces
these weapons cause mass casualties
they pose great risk for civilians when
deployed in urban areas including long
after fighting has ceased
their use is unconscionable
equally
any use of white phosphorus against
civilians or civilian infrastructure is
apparent and contrary to international
law
president not only is russia's war in
ukraine morally wrong
it is illegal
yesterday in granting ukraine's request
for provisional measures against the
russian federation the international
court of justice was clear
it was emphatic
russia must immediately suspend the
military operations in ukraine
in light of the court's decision which
is binding on the russian federation
which it cannot ignore
ireland once again calls on the russian
federation to comply with its
obligations under international law and
immediately end its aggression
unconditionally withdraw its forces
from the entire territory of ukraine
and refrain from further threat or use
of force of any kind against ukraine or
any other member state
president colleagues for three long
weeks
diplomacy has proved unavailing
for three long weeks the world has
watched this war with horror
yet
we believe there is still a chance for
peace
we urge the russian federation to do the
right thing
and commit to the diplomatic path in
good faith
it is never too late to do the right
thing
thank you
thank you president
i join others in thanking briefers for
their sobering presentations
three weeks ago russia launched its
military aggression and invaded ukraine
and since the start of the war
a ukrainian child has become a refugee
almost every second
our three million civilians have crossed
the borders into neighboring countries
seeking protection
and over 2 million people are displaced
inside ukraine
they are fleeing from the horrors of
russia's unjust and illegal war against
ukraine
from the destructive power of one of the
world's biggest war machines
from russia's shelling of homes schools
and hospitals
from russia's indiscriminate use of
explosive weapons
and their deplorable use of cluster
bombs
weapons that destroy cities
killing civilians even while they are
fleeing or hiding
the human suffering is unacceptable
we encourage countries to keep their
borders open to all those seeking safety
outside ukraine
without
discrimination
and we commend the generosity of the
neighboring countries and their
solidarity with those fleeing the war
many of those fleeing are in a
vulnerable situation as we heard from dr
teddrus
at risk of sexual and gender-based
violence trafficking and other forms of
exploitation
traumatized children and adults in need
of mental and psychosocial support
we encourage the humanitarian
organization to give priority to these
issues in their response
president
civilian must be protected at all times
and humanitarian and medical worker must
also be protected and allowed safe rapid
and unhindered access to people in need
the protection of civilians and
humanitarian access are not a matter of
choice
their legal obligation under
international humanitarian law
obligation which must be respected
and those responsible for violation must
be held accountable
president russia's war is causing
despair and suffering with global
implication
russia is responsible for the increased
food prices and higher risk of food
insecurity that many countries now face
russia's war against ukraine will
further exacerbate humanitarian crisis
death and disaster for people across
continents
russia and russia alone bears the sole
responsibility for the war and
humanitarian crisis
russia must stop its military aggression
against ukraine
russia must comply with the order by the
international court of justice to
immediately suspend its military
operation in ukraine
if russia cares about the humanitarian
suffering this war is causing
then russia should stop its senseless
and illegal war
the russian draft resolution has no
credibility it will not stop the war and
the suffering
we echo the call of the secretary
general
that political dialogue negotiation and
mediation are the only way forward
we need to see genuine talks that
translate into concrete results on the
ground
and they must be inclusive
we need to see women included
meaningfully in all talks negotiation
and mediation efforts
and for the sake of
humanity this war must stop
thank you
for
watching from norway and india has a
floor
thank you mr president
let me thank usd de carlo
unhcr assistant high commissioner
mazou
and who director general dr
gabrisas for their respective briefing
on the security and humanitarian
situation in ukraine
india continues to remain deeply
concerned at the ongoing situation
which has progressively deteriorated
since the beginning of the hostilities
the conflict has resulted
in death of civilians displacement of
thousands of people internally and
outflow of more than 3 million refugees
to neighboring countries
the humanitarian situation has worsened
particularly in the conflict zones
there is an urgent need therefore to
address the humanitarian needs of the
affected population
in this regard we support the
initiatives of the u.n and its agencies
who have mobilized whatever is possible
in the shortest possible time frame
we hope the international community will
continue to respond positively to the
humanitarian needs of the people of
ukraine including through extending
generous support to secretary general's
flash appeal and the regional refugee
response plan on ukraine
keeping in view the dire humanitarian
situation unfolding in ukraine india has
already sent over 90 tons of
humanitarian supplies to ukraine and its
neighbors as a part of the nine separate
tranche of humanitarian assistance
delivered thus far these supplies have
included medicines and other essential
relief material
we are in the process of identifying
other such requirements and sending
further supplies in the coming days
india has ensured the safe return of
about 22 500 indians from ukraine
we have also assisted nationals from 18
other countries in that process
we are deeply appreciative of the
facilitation rendered by the authorities
of ukraine and its neighboring countries
in ensuring their safe return
allow me to underscore that it is
important that the humanitarian action
is always guided by the principles of
humanitarian assistance which is
humanity neutrality impartiality and
independence these measures should not
be politicized
the reiterator called for immediate
secession of hostilities across ukraine
our prime minister has reiterated this
on several occasions and called for
immediate ceasefire and emphasized that
there is no option but the path of
dialogue and diplomacy
we stand ready to continue to engage on
these objectives in the security council
as well as with the parties in the
coming days
we continue to underline the need to
respect the u.n charter international
law and the sovereignty and the
territorial integrity of states
mr
president i thank you for convening this
meeting
and also thank the distinguished
briefers for the updated information on
the prevailing humanitarian situation in
ukraine
i also welcome the participation in this
meeting of the representatives of poland
and ukraine
mr president
ghana reiterates once more the call on
the russian federation for an
unconditional and immediate ceasefire
and for the withdrawal of all its
invading troops from the internationally
recognized borders of ukraine
the cessation of hostilities is critical
to save lives and prevent further
devastation to the ukrainian people
it remains fundamental to addressing the
worsening humanitarian situation
we remain deeply concerned about the
military escalations and the
disproportionate use of unconventional
munitions in bombarding the cities and
civilian populated areas of ukraine
and we are disheartened by the trauma
that the situation has caused especially
to the aged women and children
the parties to the conflict must
urgently commit to a humanitarian pause
to enable the evacuation and safe
passage of civilians and facilitate the
delivery of food medicine and other
essential services to those in critical
need and those who have been caught up
in the cities under siege
we also deplore the attacks on medical
facilities and call for the protection
of humanitarian workers and medical
personnel
we urge the parties to comply with their
commitments under international law and
international humanitarian law in
particular the provisions of the fourth
geneva convention of 1949 relating to
the protection of civilian persons in
the time of war
we continue to urge the parties to
accept the path of diplomacy and
dialogue in resolving their security
concerns
we believe that the good officers of the
secretary general should be leveraged to
facilitate a peaceful resolution of the
conflict
mr president in concluding i wish to
emphasize that the interest and safety
of the ukrainian people should be
prioritized and must be at the forefront
of the actions of this council and all
other international actions i thank you
for your kind attention
i thank the representative and i know
give the floor
to gabon
thank you mr president mr president
gabriel is
the conditions
all causes for concern
humanitarian personnel as well
mr president
uh i thank the briefers for their
presentations this afternoon
kenya is gravely concerned that three
weeks on
the armed conflict in ukraine has
continued unabated
the continuing reports of loss of lives
and displacement and separation of loved
ones including through
millions of refugees in just three weeks
is deeply disturbing
kenya extends
its condolences to the families who have
lost loved ones to the conflicts and
stands in solidarity with all the
affected
we commend ukraine's neighbors
for opening their borders to refugees of
multiple nationalities
and we urge them to continue ensuring
that protections sought are offered with
no discrimination on any basis and
particularly in regard to race or
religion
kenya condemns the targeting on and
destruction of civilian objects
and infrastructure
particularly residential homes hospitals
and shelters
the parties are obliged to comply with
international humanitarian law
we remind that civilians including
foreign nationals in ukraine are not
party to the conflict and must not be a
target
in this regard
all actors including the parties must
consider to prioritize the safety and
interest of civilians in accordance with
international humanitarian law
the imperative to ensure that
humanitarian passages are open and
functioning in all times cannot be
overstated
we believe that there is
an urgent need for humanitarian
resolution that reflects the unity
and the resolve of this council to
assist the people of ukraine
ultimately
the only way out of this crisis is an
immediate
and unconditional cessation of the
military campaign
we urge the parties to do this to allow
humanitarian assistance to flow and
create room for diplomacy and
constructive dialogue including through
the good offices of the u.n secretary
general towards a sustainable political
solution
we underscore the need for an urgent
resolution of this armed conflict
its impact is already being felt through
increased food prices fertilizer oil and
other essentials
by multiple countries
if it is not quickly prevented this
trend including
the added effects of unilateral
sanctions will aggravate
state
fragilities and fuel ongoing conflicts
across the world especially in the
global south
in closing mr presidents
kenya
restates its recognition of the
sovereignty
editorial integrity and the political
independence of ukraine
and i now give the floor to the
representative of brazil thank you
mr president
at the outset
i would like to thank for their
briefings miss hoss marie de carlo
the wto director general tetros
gabrezus and mr rauf mazu from
unhcr
as the conflict in ukraine lingers on
the dire humanitarian situation in the
region is further deteriorating
brazil is deeply concerned with the
growing number of civilian casualties
including children
as well as the increasing flows of
refugees and internally displaced people
according to some estimates
the number of
people impacted by the conflict is
around 18 million
of which more than 6 million are
internally displaced and nearly 3
million people have flattered ukraine
the destruction of infrastructure has
caused food shortages energy outages and
intermittent communications
under these circumstances
supply chains have been disrupted
the access to medical facilities is
impaired
medical supplies are running low
their distribution is uncertain and some
stockpiles are out of reach due to
military operation operations
hospitals and medical personnel are
struggling to provide care to the sick
and wounded
in response to the most pressing needs
for humanitarian assistance
the brazilian government has sent
leicester a donation
encompassing water purifiers around nine
tons of foods
and half a ton of medical items
totaling approximately twenty thousand
twenty thousand items donated by the
brazilian ministry of health
with the assistance of the embassy of
brazil universal
the supplies were landed at that capital
and delivered to ukraine in coordination
with the country's authorities
the international community must come to
the assistance of the people most in
need
not only those directly afflicted by the
hostilities in ukraine territory
but also refugees in the neighboring
countries
we commend
the world health organization for its
work to ensure the delivery of health
supplies to ukraine and its neighboring
countries
the availability of medical personnel
medicines and health equipment is
crucial to meet the urgent needs of
those sick and wouldn't
at this moment ukraine's health system
is under critical pressure to cope with
the demands for assistance from the many
victims of this conflict
it is distressing
to know that as of 12 march
the world health organization
had verified 31 attacks
on health care facilities in ukraine
resulting in dozens of deaths and
injuries including
health workers
the attacks against health care
are
particularly worrisome since they
deprive people of life-saving services
attacks on health care are violations of
international humanitarian law
we reiterate our position that the
immediate cessation of hostilities in
ukraine is the main condition to
guarantee the passage of civilians from
confrontative zones to safe areas
moreover
only with a comprehensive and effective
ceasefire it would be allowed the rapid
safe and unhindered access to
humanitarian assistance to those in need
i thank you mr president
very carefully to our briefers
in ukraine
in addition
military
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
it is not
um medical facilities in ukraine is
something that we have many questions
about and we'll revert to that
this has been refuted many times
this is the consequences of just
distributing weapons to whoever wants to
happen
right during this
show
um
during one single meeting of security
council that will be a guinness book
record
the fabric manufacturing fakes
and the western westerners are the
situation
and around this city well let me explain
to you why this this place is special
in the course of events in 2014-2015
those who lived in the east of the
country uh it threw um planes and tanks
against them
at the time
one was the main centers of
and the iranian
and the right sector one
airport
jail which is also a torture center with
all of the attributes
with bodies of people solitary
confinement sounds like chainsaws this
is not even the uh middle ages this is
near nazism even the players that is
precisely why the ukrainian radicals are
clinging to this cities
to to drag into
the grave almost entire uh population of
mariupol
exactly the way it was done by the nazis
in berlin in 1945 when it was besieged
they also hold people as human sure
and they place right next to residential
buildings heavy weaponry in violation of
international humanitarian law
yet
this is something that our westerners
unfortunately
the icrc statement which sheds lights
light on these facts
and in such a situation it's not a
surprise that mario has been become
almost a leader
on the number and ingeniousness
and their manufacturing has become
almost a main job of the
[Music]
too
it is very difficult
ignoring the opinion of ballistic
experts who say nothing
hit the building but rather there was an
explosion there
after all the second fake is something
that we heard about today also
russia allegedly hit the mario theater
where more than 5 000 people had sought
refuge
in actual fact already on the 13th of
march there was a widely available
public information provided by by
private people
who managed miraculously to escape
you can see the word children
the uh russian armed forces were
informed about the situation
and the building of the theater was
never considered as a target for a
striker
the excesses conducted by national
nationalist battalions and ukrainian
armed forces
before western mass media said anything
about the tragedy in donetsk which
resulted in 20 deaths
and the third fake now
allegedly is um
russia received more than 2.5 million
requests
for being evacuated into russia
unfortunately we have to state that we
have not been able to evacuate everyone
here but this is because the ukrainian
authorities are prohibiting
but
during the previous 24 hours
we managed to ensure the evacuation of
more than 31 thousand civilians
including 89 foreign nationals amongst
whom 71 osce staff
nine greek nationals and nine pakistani
nationals
and her son oblast under the control of
the russian
armed forces and categorically refused
to move over to the territories and the
key of control
the whole humanitarian operation
operation was conducted by the dnr
forces and russian armed forces without
any participation
i'd like you to draw your attention to
the fact
is 10 kilometers long
russian liberators
this is something that was seen and this
is not a surprise because the peaceful
civilians were needed
by the nazis as a human shield
and those who escaped from marijuana are
telling us about mass atrocities and
crimes conducted by the territorial
defense but the abuses against the
elderly women and children and all of
these people and being individually
provided with medical and psychological
assistance
the situation in other areas it varies
objective control including with the use
of drones
and those who managed to break through
were being
shot at
yesterday
as a result four people died and there
are
children it was natural
overall since the beginning of a special
military operation already 270 one
thousand people out of them 58 000
children have been um
evacuated
they have crossed the uh border of
russia
this includes a 31 000 individual cars
and we stand ready
russian federation we have more than 9.5
000 points of temporary housing
which remains in many places the only
possible
means of survival
ukrainian cities resell to local
entrepreneurs
these facts have been reliably
established
and involved
because there's a very high danger of
and this also is related to the possible
provocations of by the ukrainian armed
forces
we continue
sending humanitarian assistance to the
needy in ukraine
alone received more than 450 tons of
food medicines and basic
with the necessities of march our
emergency services and the ministry of
the
defense supply to
various regions of ukraine including
donbass supplied about 3 000 tons of
humanitarian
the local administrations are
threatening punishment to those who
receive
humanitarian assistance
basically every day we see um
information from western capitals that
they are providing kiev with yet another
um cargo of all kinds of weaponry
yesterday washington announced that this
week ukraine will receive from then
defense assistance to the amount of one
billion dollars
you are fueling uh this conflict pouring
oil into it it is already clear now
what kind of
tragedy resulted from simply
distributing light's weapons to anyone
who wanted them without any control i
wonder
whether the western taxpayers know about
the risks of this weaponry ending
with the terrorist groups in europe air
defense weapons for example do you
understand how dangerous it is to fuel
the situation
how dangerous it is
it was not noticed even though it
crossed over several countries from the
western point in in ukraine to zagreb
that's 700 more than 700 kilometers
no mr president
we know where they were
brain
as
including
women children than the elderly
this was not the case
would not be now dealing with a
salacious uproar
surrounding the
it stopped being humanitarian
immediately and became full of
political formulas which
ready to push it forward not in the
security council but in the general
assembly ignoring the fact that such
this kind of document will help
humanitarians nothing
in yourself
russia
would put forward its own draft
containing within it everything that the
human libertarians need
it does not contain political
assessments
and this is not the kind of assessment
that you can find in other humanitarian
resolutions either and we open this
document for the co-sponsorship by all
you and members
is not something that satisfies western
countries
and this shows the true goal sponsor
the sponsors of the first so-called
humanitarian
[Music]
pressure
by western partners that their arms are
being twisted including blackmail
instead of blackmailing threats
albania has disseminated a letter
difficult it is for those countries to
withstand this kind of onslaught
emergency meeting
to discuss again
laboratories in ukraine using the new
documents
in the course of the special military
operations
and right now
of china
thank you mr president
mr president
director andrew
humanitarian situation in ukraine and
depose the reported increase in civilian
casualties and refugees
the pressing task now is to call for
maximum restraint from all parties and
to ensure safety and security of all
civilians including women and children
and meeting their basic humanitarian
needs
so as to prevent the occurrence of a
larger scale humanitarian crisis
china supports the work by the relevant
parties in maintaining communication
ensuring safe and impeded humanitarian
corridor and further facilitating
personnel evacuation and humanitarian
assistance
the number of refugees and displaced
persons caused by the conflict is still
on the rise
bringing
huge impact on ukraine and the
surrounding countries
china
unhcr
and whl among others in scientific
conducting operations and mobilizing the
international community to assist
all those in need
in the recent past
some people of african or middle east
encountered difficulties during
evacuations
this should be taken seriously and
addressed properly or
refugees regardless of color race or
religion
pays high attention to the humanitarian
situation in ukraine and has put forward
a six-point proposal the red cross
society of china has provided ukraine
with three batches of humanitarian
supplies
with the third one containing
milk powder and quilts for children
specifically helping the red cross
society of ukraine assist displaced
children affected by the conflict
we welcome
any initiative or proposal from any
party that contributes to alleviating
and resolving the humanitarian crisis in
ukraine
the security council has a primary
responsibility for maintaining
international peace and security and
should therefore play a positive role in
easing the humanitarian situation in
ukraine china hopes that the council can
stay united on the humanitarian issue
and demonstrate a constructive attitude
mr president
the international community shares the
common aspirations
cease fire at an early date to elevate
the situation on the ground and to
prevent civilian casualties this is also
the exploration of china
to date
russia and ukraine have held four rounds
of negotiations
keeping the negotiations going means
there is a chance for ceasefire
and that there is a chance for a
peaceful future
china remains committed to promoting
peace through negotiations we support
the u.n and the parties concerned in
vigorously carrying out good offices we
also hope
that all parties will do more to
facilitate peace talks
and
that wanting use of sanctions will not
solve any problem but will instead
create new problems
given the sluggish recovery in global
economy
ever escalating sanctions
are undermining stability in
international industrial chain and
supply chain thus exacerbating food and
energy crisis damaging people's
livelihoods in all countries developing
countries in particular
and triggering new humanitarian
consequences this is also an issue that
the security council shall pay attention
to when addressing the humanitarian
situation in ukraine thank you mr
president
[Music]
of mexico
thank you very much
is
the largest numbers
and medicines
attacks on medical insulation to ukraine
and the fact that
honestly
attacking
installations
as well
foreign
[Music]
a fundamental
is
[Music]
in which we have been engaged
is
foreign
such as
refugees
yes
response
you have the floor
thank you very much i was momentarily
pleased to hear that the russians
were pulling down the vote on their
fascicle humanitarian resolution which
was doomed to fail
we know if russia really truly cared
about humanitarian uh crises the one
that it created it could simply stop its
attacks on the people of ukraine
but instead they want to call for
another security council meeting to use
this council as a venue for its
disinformation and for promoting its
propaganda
let us not forget that russia is the
aggressor here they are the ones that
are creating a pretext for attacks on
their own people
and we can't be fooled by by their
efforts here
uh they have troops inside of ukraine
they are killing people inside of
ukraine that is the reason for us being
here today not to deal with their
propaganda thank you
representative of the united states
mr president
distinguished members of the security
council
madame under secretary
general de carlo
director general assistant high
commissioner
i also recognize the representative of
the aggressor state president here in
the permanent state of the soviet union
let me begin with a quote
the operation is developing successfully
and in strict accordance
with plans
that have been previously
approved
end of quote
said by putin
yesterday three weeks after the
unprovoked and unjustified russian
invasion of ukraine started
over these weeks the international
community was wrestled
with the question
why
why has the russian federation decided
to cosplay the nazi third reich by
attacking the peaceful neighboring state
and plunging the region into war
what are the reasons and what is the
plan
and yesterday we got the answer
killing ukrainian children
108 innocent souls so far
let me quote again
success
in the strict accordance
with the plans
approved
previously
according to putin
children are deliberate target
given yesterday's bombardment of the
mario paul drama theater
a shelter for hundreds of local
residents mostly women and children
despite the big signs
children painted on the road on both
sides of the building
being clearly visible
russian pilots dropped an aerial bomb
the building was fully damaged but the
shelter fortunately withstood
it did not turn into one of more mass
grave as putin's plan probably
envisaged
previously approved
of course putin's plan does not limit
murders to children
only all civilian ukrainians and foreign
citizens are under threat
the office of the high commissioner for
human rights recorded
726 confirmed cases of killing of
civilians
while believing that the real figures
are considerably higher
and they are
indeed
just yesterday in the city of chernyhuv
53 civilian residents were killed by
russian bombs and shells
on the same day
in marefa
haki region
21 people were killed following russian
shelling that destroyed the local school
and residential buildings
the plan is also to raise ukrainian
cities to the ground kharkiv sumi waln
in mariupol
painful ukraine and the entire world and
an eternal shame for russia
almost 2400 confirmed victims among the
civilian population
ninety percent of the city's
infrastructure has been destroyed
russian troops seized one of the
hospitals
gathered 400 civilians there and used
the building as a military position
hiding behind civilians as a human
shield
let me quote
the sufferings of marijuana must not
become the future of ukraine end of
quote
said by peter mauer the icrc president
who is currently in ukraine
the plan of putin is to violate the
agreements on ceasefire and safe passage
for the civilian population from the
temporarily occupied territories
yesterday russian troops held a convoy
of civilian vehicles headed from
mariupol to zaparilla
five people were killed
many injured including children
and the plan is previously approved
to terrorize local residents who remain
in the territories ceased by russian
troops
small villages where the russian
soldiers stay suffer the most
russians break into houses
throw people out into the streets
take their food
eyewitness reports of tortures
abductions of local officials and even
extrajudicial killings come from across
the occupied territories
enforcing ukrainians to flee their homes
as refugees has also been a part of this
barbarossa style plan
almost 3.2 million refugees have left
ukraine so far
against the backdrop of the increasingly
aggravated humanitarian situation russia
has there to table a draft humanitarian
resolution of the security council
an appeal by a serial killer
to the end members to co-sponsor this
most egregious hypocrisy is outrageous
they may like to think twice
if they want before they rather before
they dive into the blood of children and
adults executed by the russian military
in ukraine
and let me quote saint patrick in this
regard
never trust a dog to watch your food
at the same time there is no doubt
that action on the humanitarian front in
the u.n is urgently required and i
encourage all responsible nations to
support the relevant efforts in the
general assembly
i also encourage all to join the group
of friends of accountability following
the aggression against ukraine
co-founded by albania colombia
denmark the marshall island
islands
the netherlands and ukraine
this group will act as a forum among um
member states for the discussion and
promotion of accountability measures in
ukraine following the russian military
aggression
distinguished members of the security
council
yesterday the international court of
justice delivered its order on
provisional measures in the case
concerning allegations of genocide under
the convention on prevention and
punishment of the crime of genocide
ukraine versus russian federation
the court ordered that the russian
federation shall immediately suspend the
military operations that it commenced on
the 24th february 2022
in the territory of ukraine
despite the order being binding on
russia under the iran charter today the
kremlin has openly and bludently
disregarded it
stating that they and i quote cannot
take this order into account end of
quote because there is no i quote
agreement between the sites and the
quote
and should it be surprising for us
i don't think so
as from the very first instance of
russia's presence in the u.n it was in
content of the u.n charter
that was the case when russia was
allowed to occupy the soviet seat in the
u.n and the security council
that was the case in georgia
in syria
as well as in ukraine's crimea and on
bus in 2014
i encourage the security council members
to exercise their duties
envisaged by the article
94.2 of the u.n charter to make
recommendations or decide upon measures
to be taken in the case of russia's
fella to comply with the obligations
incumbent upon it under the judgment
rendered by the court
mr president
perpetration induce
traumatic stress although known as pits
is a form of post-traumatic stress
disorder
its symptoms are caused by being an
active participant in causing trauma
sufferers of pits
may be found in many roles
such as soldiers
or executioners
where they are expected to cause trauma
including death
but diplomats
especially here in the united nations
especially here in the security council
compared to the more well-known and
understood ptsd
there are there appears to be greater
severity and different symptom patterns
for those affected by pits
the case of the military aggression of
russia against ukraine and the mass
atrocities perpetrated by the russian
army
ordered by putin
and defended by the russian diplomats
will be examined by scholars and
scientists
including in the areas of sociology
history
philosophy
psychiatry and theology
today however i would like to quote
from into the abyss
a documentary about executioners
of the death penalty
one guard
began crying and shaking uncontrollably
when i quote
the eyes of all the inmates
he had executed
began flashing before
him end of quote
ambassador
do the eyes of ukrainian children
women and elderly killed by the russians
flash before you
if they do we may consider how to
how to sponsor a decision
to help you deal with perpetration
inducted traumatic stress
but now have some descendancy
and stop the egregious manipulation of
the security council
it is obscene
it would be too much dignifying
for the russian delegation if i end it
like here
like that
instead i would like
to quote
it
by dario francischini
the italian member of the government
who tweeted today
italy is really is ready to rebuild the
theater in mariupol
the cabinet of ministers
has approved my proposal to offer
ukraine
the resources and means to rebuild it as
soon as possible
theaters
of all countries
belong to the whole humanity end of
quote
and i thank you
representative of the ukraine
to the representative of poland mr
president distinguished members of
security council i would like to thank
under secretary general
and the briefers for their important
interventions today
and i shall start by paying tribute to
the fearless ukrainian soldiers and
civilians alike
who defend their homeland freedom and
the u.n charter
they fight also for those who were
forced to flee
i should also express gratitude to the
work done by the u.n orchard unhsr
who and and its partners for maintaining
their
presence across ukraine and continuing
deliver to deliver the of the systems
excellencies
the security council has gathered here
today to discuss the fastest growing
humanitarian and refugee crisis since
the second world war the consequence of
the russian aggression on ukraine
in light of this i would like to stress
the following points
firstly
this is 100 a war of choice
and the methods of waging it is also the
matter of choice
it is russia that decided to refer to
brutal force and discriminate weapons as
well as brutal siege tactics
now they go as far as targeting
journalists and kidnapping mires of
ukrainian cities
in other words the aggressor decided to
change the nature of this conflict
it is a clear manifestation that the
russia deliberately
chose to create a humanitarian
catastrophe in ukraine and bluntly
disregards all the principles of
international humanitarian law
and this should worry us all
disregarding the national law has been a
pattern that russia pursued in syria and
other places to underpin this approach
earlier today the kremlin has rejected
an order by the national court of
justice on the united nations highest
court to cease his attack on ukraine
secondly
without resolving the dire humanitarian
situation there will be no peace
therefore we urge russia to change its
military modus operandi and allow full
and impeded commentarian access and
relief to those in need
the safe passage of civilians from
different cities affected by the
conflict must be allowed
take the situation in mariopol where
still around 350.000
remain trapped in the cities food water
and medicines continue to dry up
these people require urgent humanitarian
assistance and are exposed to safety and
security risks
therefore we call for immediate
ceasefire and humanitarian access to
most affected areas
thirdly
the humanitarian consequences of the
ongoing war are not limited to
ukrainians in their own territory
those who had fled remain affected too
already more than 3 million were forced
to leave ukraine as a result of russia's
military aggression
we have already reached the number of
over 1.9 million people who crossed our
border since february 24th
most of them found the shelter in poland
we have registered already 170
nationalities on our border
that means it considers us all and we
are all the victims of this aggression
excellencies
as a neighbor and close friend of
ukraine we see firsthand the dramatic
humanitarian consequences of this war
every day on the polish ukrainian border
we are witnessing growing number of
people who cross the border severely
traumatized
we believe that the involvement of u.n
bodies and agencies experience in
dealing with this kind of needs together
with the continued efforts of the polish
authorities will bring rapid and
appropriate
the spirit of solidarity poland will
continue to admit and provide shelter
food health care and safety to every
person in need regardless of their
nationality race or religion's creed
aside from the
institutional care thousands of polish
people are organizing in a bottom-up way
showing the solidarity of ukraine
opening their homes to refugees and
volunteering and reception centers
excellencies as i'm delivering this
speech paulin's president's spouse
agatha conhauser duda is building up
international coalition of first ladies
and high-end highnesses and all the
peoples of goodwill to effectively
protect those in vulnerable situations
namely women children elderly persons
and persons with disabilities many of
them with post-traumatic
disorder
the polish government has urgently
implemented new immigration measures for
ukrainian citizens fleeing their country
the new law that took effect on monday
legalizes the state of citizens of
ukraine in order to enable them to take
up employment and provide them with
healthcare education and accommodation
in poland
it also offers temporary financial help
to policy citizens who welcome refugees
in their homes
ukrainian citizens may apply for
one-time subsidy to answer their basic
needs
the government will allocate funds for
schooling of ukrainian students
every ukrainian citizens fleeing the war
has been guaranteed access to the public
healthcare system in the same way as
polish citizens have
we will continue to provide assistance
to ukrainian citizens fleeing the
horrors of war brought on them by russia
and i can tell you already we got the 45
thousands of pupils subscribed to public
schools from ukraine
but we and the other countries of the
region which i see the
ambassadors here in the room we all need
[Laughter]
that applies to many
u.s sponsored laboratories around the
world
are you planning to use biological
weapons
okay
hey
hello
thank you
oh
greece
yes
um
his name's
all right
all right
bye
who is putting fuel on fire except the
russian army
my house
i still here
foreign
i'm
an improvement on the end of this
horrible war
all right
are you still paranoid with it no anyway
tell me an improvement no there is no
improvement the actions of the russian
federation uh continue to be very
brazen and uh
the atrocities are taking place
every day unfortunately
tomorrow the president of the united
states is going to speak with the leader
of china
because he's going to ask that china is
not going to help
no no the question is from what the
chinese ambassador said today
can i ask you uh after many weeks of
putting questions to me can you identify
yourself please
when the time comes he may
all right have a good day goodbye
oh
i think
uh
okay
so
is
okay
okay
oh yeah
you